CLAIMS O T
VIOLENCE.
HOLES.SENIFICANTLY SIZED
>> THEY E.AS SO LOUD
MHUSBAND I
COULD HAVE BEEN
SPENDING THE NIGHT.
orter:WAS ABOUT N BULLETS FIREDO
O'MALL
SH FOUICFICIALS TARGETED IN A S.
REVEALS ANN PENA, FOR
BEING THF
SHOONG FORMER REPUBLICAN 2 LLOT
TWEETEHE SITAND
NEVEEDEDIS OIN
XICO.
>>MY NAME'S SOLOMO.
CAN I WITHBI
O'MAEY
>> Reporter: RING VIDEOMSHORTLY
H
PROSECUTORTION
ANCORDINTMEN THEADDRESSES TO A
CARRE S, WRITING"THEY JUST CERTD
THEY WERLLY LAUGHING."
OSPENAY  TWO
F THE VICTIMWE
EIGHT BULLETS WERE FIRED AT HE E
HO FINTO THE
ROOM WHEREHEWI GRANDDAUGHTER>>
ELD OFFICIALS IN  GOVERNMENT THT
THINK IT INVOKE
VIOLENCEN IONS>> Reporter: AS TY
THE MESSAGE FROMEW TOGETHER, TO
VI WILL NEVEOP
AMERING HER DUTY Reporte T
FECOUNTSINDICTMENT.
THEY VFRCTION ERENCE,